let's get right into audience questions
for this week first one's interesting
relates to a thing
to a few different things we've talked
about over the last few years and the
question is
what is the most likely future of
socialism
in the united states uh if you watched
the recent
a state of the union addresses from
donald trump you would know that this
powerful defiant declaration that the
u.s
will never be a socialist country
is both an impossible prediction to make
because the truth is we're terrible at
predicting things even five years out
who knows what the us could look like 20
30 50 100 years out but it's also
particularly
it's meaninglessly propagandistic in the
sense that there's no threat that the
u.s is about
to become socialist despite donald trump
continuing to campaign on
biden's been taken over by the
socialists the people
trump claims are controlling biden
aren't
by and large actual socialists and
certainly there's nothing
socialistic about joe biden's policy so
the fear-mongering about the u.s
becoming socialist is very very silly
but it does
seem to at least activate some of the
people on the right but i think those
people are mostly supporting donald
trump anyway
i think it's essentially a wash so then
we get to
a trump-free discussion of the possible
future of socialism in the united states
as i have said before
i have seen no evidence that if the us
is to become a socialist country and
again
this is not about my views i'm not a
socialist i'm a social democrat which is
a form of highly regulated
capitalism if the country is to become
socialist
i believe that you would need to see
first of all
actual socialists have some amount of
power in the united states now this
could be socialist groups
or socialist politicians right now i
don't see either
and i believe it would be incremental it
would go through social democracy
accelerationism is the idea when applied
to socialism capitalism
that by accelerating capitalism
which some socialists believe will fail
some marxist some communists believe
will fail you
accelerate the eventual revolution
that will turn the country socialistic
much has been said theoretically about
that and written theoretically about
that i believe that in practice
at this point in time again in five
years maybe i'd have a different view
because things dramatically change
right now i don't see how for example
giving trump another four years and
cutting regulations and giving more
market power
i don't think that if that causes a
breakdown
it results in the united states becoming
socialist
if and and so this is why i've said time
and again to actual socialists of which
there are relatively few in the united
states
many of the people who even think they
are socialists aren't really socialists
up for now you should just be joining
the fight for social democracy because
the path or let me put it a different
way
the best proof that you the united
states should go in that direction
would be to go in that direction and
that would mean
uh looking at healthcare more like
northern european countries
look at it looking at taxation more the
way northern european countries look at
it look at education
social welfare programs etc
in the last decade we have seen
socialist go from really more of an
insult and not something many people
would use to describe themselves
to kind of like a pretty ho-hum you know
it's just a word it's almost become
like progressive although it means very
different things where trump says all
his opponents are socialists very few
people really believe it
young people are more okay with the term
than we've seen people be in a very long
time so i think that
and it's not for me to give advice to
the actual socialists not being one but
if you are an
actual socialist you should capitalize
on
the most positive or least negative view
of socialism that there's been in the us
in a long time
by pushing the country in any ways that
are possible in that direction
the best argument you can make for
socialism being great
would be for social democracy to work
really well
and if we ever got to that point then i
and the socialists would be on different
sides
uh but but right now even though many of
the socialists
believe they're on a different side than
me the next step whether you want social
democracy as the end point or you want
socialism as the end point
would be to move in that direction when
it comes to all of the major
uh areas of policy in the united states
it's certainly not going to happen with
another four years of donald trump